of him like gladiator I knew I wanted to
find a metaphor for mortality because
the film at the end of the day would be
partly about mortality and I wouldn't
discover the symbol of that until the
very last two days of photography when I
was in Tuscany and I've got a double
standing up in his Roman leather armor
and tunic he's standing waist-deep in
wheat and he's actually stroking the
corn and that wheat or the corn like
that and whichever you if you stand with
you'd almost certainly do that and I was
watching that one thinking right there's
the opening shot of the movie so he got
a Steadicam you following through that
becomes the opening of the film it also
becomes the lead into the idea of heaven
because that's where he will go
eventually and then you connect when he
talks early on to Marcus Aurelius which
says tell me about your home he's
actually describing the perfection
that's in his own mind which in a funny
kind of way is heaven because that's
where his family died so it all kind of
connected up and that's that I think
that very much comes out of my
background as um as you know in art
school without question